guys political correspondent Murray
Aurora joins me now so Michelle moan
stepping back for a period of time from
the Lords
exactly Jane So Michelle Moon the
baroness that's been kind of drowning in
these allegations over the past few days
since the revelations began in the
Guardian newspaper is taking a leave of
absence with immediate effect while she
as it's put by her team clears her name
now we know that her office Michelle
Moon's office have said that they're
going to be taking potentially legal
action about these allegations against
her but what's really interesting is so
far she still remains a Tory Pierce she
still has the Tory whip now it's
understood that the conservative party
are essentially waiting for the Lord's
standards committee investigation to
conclude before they make a decision
about whether to withdraw the whip from
baroness moon but obviously this comes
with the backdrop of what some would see
as potentially dodgy dealings around
covid contracts now obviously these are
still just allegations but if they are
proven to be true it could end up
slightly tarnishing the Tori's record
when it comes to cover contracts and
their handling of the pandemic now the
labor party as you said you showed that
clip of Angela Rayner they are highly
critical not just of this particular
deal but in general the kind of
so-called VIP Lane where they see it as
those who with the WhatsApp numbers of
ministers or government officials who
are essentially fast-tracked to
potentially be able to get covered
contracts during the pandemic now the
health secretary Steve Barkley has been
up in the Commons just this afternoon
trying to kind of justify and defend the
government's decisions around those
cover contracts and try and explain the
rush and the pressure that the
government was under
Mr Speaker it ignores both the pressure
of time at the start of the pandemic and
also the fact that this was an
international competition with countries
competing for very scarce resources it
is also the case that over 19 000
companies were offering PPE only 2 600
Mr Speaker passed initial due diligence
checks
are you see him from that clip there
they're trying to explain
Ed actually would try to do their best
when it came to these covert contracts
and perhaps Mrs mistakes were made but
overall the intentions were good and you
know they always tried to point to that
uh vaccine rollout that was a big
success now the labor party is we're
expecting them to attempt to present a
humble address motion this afternoon now
we've just heard in the past couple of
hours that the government are not going
to pose that motion which basically
means that documents relating to medpro
that company associated with baroness
moon will be revealed so people can try
and look into these dealings with Med
Pro and potentially baroness moans
involvement now I've been speaking to
Tory MPS just to gauge a reaction on
this one tour EMP told me MPS aren't
prepared to compromise their reputations
by voting to protect others it's the
legacy of the Owen Patterson vote and
that's important to remember because it
was about a year ago just over a year
ago when all of this began button where
the Tory party was very much kind of
seen as modern sleaze around protecting
their own around that vote protecting
Owen Patterson and MPS feel they've
learned that lesson and they don't want
to get into that again so for now Rishi
sunak is very much dodged a bullet ahead
of pmqs Tomorrow this would have been an
open goal for the labor party to strike
at but at the same time as we know
British sunak the Prime Minister still
has all of the strikes coming in
Christmas and rebellions about house
building and onshore wind and offshore
wind so realistically he's still got a
huge amount of problems to deal with but
this now potentially is one less